o acerto foi com essa coisa que te
esqueci joão de deus noite são os outros
rosto é que não fui
sinto que estou a abrir mentalidades
demonstrado que as suas listas de frente
são tão capazes de controlá la
eu entrei no jornalismo mas sempre com
aquele site guardado em um ser ator aos
27 anos mal nesse ambiente o conselho
tem mãe papel como é todo em cima de
explicar às pessoas que ser diferente
não era serem frio e todos nós somos
diferentes
[Música]
eu quis mostrar às pessoas naquele dia
que eu era capaz
é assim que eu sou é assim que tem que
me aceitar e tem que conseguir para nos
superar a mim próprio e mostrar
ser diferente não é ser frio
o dia
e é pra mim uma honra enorme entrar no
negócio a presença muito obrigado e do
extremamente nervoso por vários um disco
porque tenho tempo reduzido com deus e
outro porque não tem nada de especial
para vencer a realizar 10
eu não sou empresário de sucesso
infelizmente não inventei a cura para
uma doença rara e também no final no
qual figura que também estou preparado
fisicamente novos assim concluiu apertar
a mão isso também deixa um caloroso não
mas não vai dar conselhos a ninguém
muito menos dizer o que você tem que
fazer ou não porque vocês vão perceber
ao longo desta rápida história que não
sou exemplo não vos vai ensinar news
igreja em uma fórmula mágica processo
foi de apenas contar uma história uma
história de superação uma história de
determinação dos sonhos uma história de
compromisso e de decisões uma história
onde senhora onde saí com uma história
onde o falhas para vencer
é verdade eu costumo dizer em tom de
brincadeira mas muito a sério
vamos contar uma história de iões heróis
reais não e ficção científica heróis que
assumiram compromisso contornar
obstáculos fernando roubá-los tim nós na
vida muitas vezes
trilhamos um caminho pensamos que é o
caminho mais correto mas e único a
atingir o nosso objetivo
e quando aparece o primeiro obstáculo
frente nós desistimos porque pensamos
que é impossível derrubar ea os tacos
impossível de salvar o ataque a quem
podemos ser hipócritas e não posso ver
um cristiano ronaldo mas não há um único
obstáculo que não conseguiu se controlar
e não conseguiu dar a volta e por isso
muitas vezes têm que poder tem que sair
daqui o caminho trilhado completo e
protesto tempo que for preciso vou
entrar mais à frente que às vezes basta
nós usarmos algo simples que todos nós
temos dentro de nós
é sobre isso que você quer falar sobre
as ferramentas de contornar os
obstáculos e acima de tudo uma história
quando difícil não signifiquem possível
vamos contar essa história que estava
ter uma máquina que pudesse viajar atrás
no tempo
acho que não foi inventado pelos
fazedores talvez um dia eu inventei essa
máquina vier atrás do tempo vamos contar
histórias sobre
um casal um casal jovem que migrou em
busca do sonho de vida dele era ter um
pequeno restaurante as misturas avós
meus tios avós emigraram para frança
foram e quando regressaram à minha avó
cumpriu seu sonho 5 novo não partilhava
vem aqui com a abrir seu próprio
restaurante tiveram duas filhas
eles ficaram uma família normal na
família feliz itu com 16 anos pensa em
tudo menos responsabilidades da vida
quer aproveitar ao máximo que ela tem
patrulhado a futura mãe com 16 anos
apaixonada pelo pai o rapaz mais velho
tem a mania que era de grandes blocos e
engravidam e um short é um som e imagina
minha filha com 16 anos chegaram até mim
e dizer pai tô grávida
basta fazer o som mas depois de superado
aquele choque depois daquela família e
tomar a decisão de seguir em frente
ainda mas não estava aqui sentada falar
com vocês um sonho sonho crianças planos
faz expectativas durante nove meses a
minha mãe abusar de uma criança
apesar de ser uma criança que não queria
que o filho está sendo muito com as duas
mãos
o time sonhar criar o meu pai queria que
o filho fosse jogador de futebol como eu
pelo menos mortos melhor é preciso muito
confessa o senhor é preciso um movimento
fazem são de crianças planos e aquela
máquina de viajar atrás do tempo eu
gostava que ela traz de 29 de outubro
pois deixo aqui minha morada por mandar
emprestou coisa a fazer antes às 9 da
manhã no quarto da maternidade da minha
mãe quando aquela mulher ou maior murro
no estômago que alguma vez é possível
ter silva quando durante nove meses dos
sonhos e em fundos funções são
destruídos porque minha mãe percebeu que
afinal não podia abraçar o mundo com as
duas mãos porque não tinha
eu vi a minha avó demorar 15 dias o
governo corta maternidade e meu pai
nosso e as caras como o pai pra mim na
minha opinião vou também um enorme
buraco no estômago percebeu de uma forma
muito dura que afinal o filho nunca
poderia partilhar o gosto de passar a
bola e passar mal estar e jogar a bola
com ele porque infelizmente o filho para
o tempo
[Música]
eu fui na china disse que querem sair
pro futebol pernas era aquilo que queria
naquele momento que eu gostava de estar
no quarto da maternidade e perceberam
daquela mulher recuperou o fogo quando
os médicos me trouxeram no curto eles
eram o filho é diferente
é ali que eu gostava do estado
a primeira frase da minha mãe eu uso
todos os dias à frente do espanhol
quando acorda de manhã quando os médicos
disseram que o filho é diferente clara e
abril o consultor
a primeira frase da minha mãe foi podia
ser pior
pô podia ser pior se o dígito vídeo
foram destruídos disse pior
minha mãe
[Música]
quanto à primeira vista ficou amor da
vida dela e nós ouvimos ao longo da
nossa vida e pensamos que é clichê que o
amor vez todas as barreiras
é verdade é verdade aquela mulher não
podia dar nada senão o amor e foi a
forma que ela encontrou para dar a volta
aqui no obstáculo e entrar mais à frente
não imagina o tempo que elas tenham
proibido mas ela usou algo tão simples
que todos nós temos dentro amor e
aceitou e podia ser pior
claro que meu pai não conseguiu subir as
escadas claro que aquela família teve
que usar a dívida é feito compromisso
cisões e tomar uma grande decisão de não
dar o máximo de conforto possível em
trazer para casa sempre será o
suficiente pra mim mas é aquilo que eles
não podiam dar o máximo que for possível
trouxeram para casa como o vôo jacini
chateado gostaram da minha avó é abrir
uma loja de artesanato que não vendia
nada zero
eu fui primeiro empreendedor de sucesso
nem família e 15 e vive numa aldeia
pequenina toda a gente crie vergonha é
diferente toda a gente nem vergonha
dizer que o a propósito então comprava
uma peça do arroz meus avós e no final e
podemos ver o é diferente e sempre
perguntavam se tornar os grandes heróis
da minha vida estava claro qual lhe
fazer no sentido de enfrentar a ser
inferior sempre entrava por ferramentas
para um dia usar eu eu eu
o meu vôo vocês vão perceber se
conseguia acabar a história a tempo
é o homem da minha vida e é o homem da
minha vida e fez nenhuma campanha
eventual que eu vou carregar a minha
vida toda se encaixa numa tábua porque
os médicos dizem que não conseguia
sentar se quer quanto mais andar
então um novo vôo ou isto e eu conta
depois voltava no sítio e turismo punha
lá e eu tomava e um dia que eu não tomo
banho onde iremos sentar e eu conta que
um dia queria ser o dono das minhas
próprias decisões
ia ser eu a decidir o que quero para mim
possível ou não com os outros e então
contatou os médicos 900 e 800 e foi
internada em alcoitão um hospital muito
conceituado e ao então eu deixei de um
centavo
regressei não tinha amor não tinha minha
família eu diria não consegui porque
treinar duas horas chorava e às quatro
da manhã do dia 21 de maio km em uma
maior precisão da vida dentro ensinou
nós não vi não devemos viver no estilo
de vida
ridículo está pendente de tudo e buscar
eu imagino que era ele não ter ido viver
a vida toda e se tiver sido e se eu
tivesse feito não nós temos de nós temos
de fazer
nós temos que olhar pra vencer e ter
sido a decisão mais errada mas eu não
consegui ver se aquela dúvida foi buscar
eu lembro tarde o médico ou sentado
frente a frente estarão brincar no chão
e me dizer lhe o seu filho vai sentar
quanto mais andar em pleno as causas do
motim e quatro anos se eu contar a sua
história agora e disse não deixar mim
não vou ficar ou não ficar nem mais um
minuto não consegue sentar foi praticado
em tese moura e quando cheguei a casa a
primeira coisa que fiz foi o pátio atrás
da casa onde estava que ela estava
repleta de encaixes sentar estava
carregado de deus e eles tomaram a
decisão com o doutor gustavo teve um
novo mal estar no meu filho vamos
arriscar vamos acreditar em si porque
sozinho lá lá num tamanho ou vindo de
pessoas que é clichê juntos somos mais
fortes somos muito mais fortes
se não fossem os heróis aceitaram amargo
acreditar em mim porque não pule lutem
por mim que eu vou conseguir não tinha
chegado aqui nem que seja com erros em
conjunto em equipa e foi assim que
fizeram as duas primeiras provas
femininas não eram estas quatro
eu lembro de estar no ginásio ficou com
aquelas barras paralelas tarde os
médicos e juninho e minha mãe e eles
disserem anda aquela história vantagem
indo eu tentei dar o primeiro passo com
os produtos e quando tentei dar-lhe
escolher logo eu gosto está na
perspectiva fiquem no chão lembrando que
os pés da minha mãe para me levantar e
os médicos não deixaram
a realidade é que ninguém vai levantar
fazendo as minhas fraquezas forças e dar
uma aula para aquelas barras levantar
sozinho e percebi é conhecido o primeiro
foi lançado na grande vitória da minha
vida tive forças para levantar ainda que
o dia não era o fim
sente mais forte com quatro anos e tem
muito mais forte conseguindo nos manter
sozinhos fim de semana fosse levantar na
teoria e levantar o resto da vida toda
porque não perseguir para falhar
para vencer o químico foi a primeira a
assumir um compromisso com o próprio
compromisso mais importante da minha
vida 2 nenhum passo e amanhã mudar de
roupa e outra de rodar três certamente
vou cair mas chegará o dia em que
consegui dar dez passos chacaíto é como
os nomes de vida tu tens ideias não os
vi não um dia chegar a um sim instituto
tem que acreditar em si próprio e
possuir impossível depende de mim és tu
decides o que é impossível praticam não
são os outros
estou muito faz muitos digam que não
acredita na justiça e apresentar funk
traz um sim e é muito mais seguro é algo
muito mais forte porque foi construído
foi conduzido os seus fracassos e não
volta nunca falhar da forma como foi
gasta uma vez nunca a minha mãe ia
continuar o início da minha vida
escreveu uma escola em prática a lei
maior samsung foi expulso e mesmo que
fosse vítima de preconceito é normal a
pessoa declara ter deixado seu filho
área da gestão
ela não tinha que ter medo eu sei que
novos diz que os desde o início não
podia dar conselho nenhum
ela não tinha que ter saído porque ela
ensinou a gostar de mim como era
pode parecer um negócio entre mas eu
gosto nem começou e já é o maior segredo
fui o único que eu quero passar nesta
pequena conversa aceita como essa com
todos os seus defeitos com todas as suas
virtudes e acho que tem que estar aqui
como isso nós temos vindo a tentar
agradar a quem nos rodeia gosta de nós
com nós próprios não estamos onde é que
vamos chegar a lado nenhum
profissionalmente somente é muito mais
fortes se está a assistir como essa
eu estava me levavam para 8 no fim não
tivesse adotado nos últimos anos mais
tarde não
as pessoas não vêem isso pensava que
tinha duas garras todas as demais nem
pernas era surdo também diziam coisas
assim mais vale a pena eu não ter mexido
dói
talvez isso eo que carregavam todo dia
nessa frase meu quarto um dia sou eu que
vou mostrar se houve ou não são vocês os
meus colegas na escola perguntavam
quantas mãos ou não quem não te espero
não é que não temos mais filmes em
gravadas
a série vai marcar desde clínica mater o
herói de luz
as pessoas não achavam piada dizem paulo
quer falar com ele no ar e fica mais
complicado havia alguém em minha casa
que eu achava que estava resolvido
um dia entrei no quarto meu pai e
percebi isso vocês podem subir agora se
quiserem como parte de um fechado na
gaveta o equipamento benfica e uma
histórias femininas que permite o pai
tinha desistido do sonho e fechados ou
naquela revista não há ninguém nesta
sala que não conheçam depois não venham
aqui ninguém que não tenha medo de ir
atrás de chances em um ritmo
nós adiamos os nossos filmes não é o
seguinte nós abrimos mão de deus
pensamos que só uma porta de entrada só
uma forma de concretizar e só tenho a
chave a várias portas e compromisso que
eu assumi aquele foi um dia vou dar
tantas vezes a volta a este sonho
encontrar uma porta de entrada possam
ser jogador do foco no meu pai mas tem
que entrar neste mundo tem que trabalhar
não esteja muito certo
temos colegas pensavam que a bola para
baixo debaixo do braço o campo e eu não
podia viver no ici posso ficar com vocês
e posava pontos faz avaliza analisa não
quer ser bonito mas não é fácil
eu faço a minha maneira posso tentar
detonar os outros heróis da minha vida
porque acharam tentar a minha maneira
não julgarão por ter de enfrentar uma
oportunidade eo naquela tarde foi
criança mais feliz do mundo sim porque
em casa já era um craque cristiano
ronaldo que é mais novo também reservado
fizeram ficaram rui costa está o pé de
apoio como dizia estar ao pé que matava
e ao tomar a decisão de levar um torneio
de futsal fantástico
eu fui cair no erro de perguntar ao
árbitro se podia ajudar com as provas
que eu não sabia se eu andava a todos
nem pernas eu não tinha
eu passei por aí posso chegar e eu
adiantar trabalho pode pode muito bem
está tudo muito inclusive por aí eu
comecei no banco a opção do treinador é
o primeiro titular logo agora quando um
treinador mandou entrar numa bola ao
primeiro poste a bola parada
eu passei a correr por cento a vítima
era de festa
eu mato o braço direito marcou o árbitro
mal amarelo guarda redes que acaba de
sofrer golos você não sabe jogar assim e
amarelo guarda redes quilômetros nosso
grande herói da minha vida que eu
naquele papel me disse não perceber nada
toca com quem as pernas agora quem
espera agora não têm sede ou
funcionários só se quiser eu sair mas eu
jogo assim eu não já aplicamos só quando
a proposta feita à mão não exclui caí e
fui atrás desse sonho e tirei o curso de
treinador de futebol claro interesse no
jogador de futebol para ensinar a
gráfica foi a forma como o dae entrada
que o sonho de ir logo estagiar no seu
nível e fica porto sporting perdeu
grande oportunidade para mostrar o
efeito o 15º mais uma palestra na
groundforce
o sporting também não se tem mostrado e
fui dar uma palestra na academia ainda
bem que não foi há pouco tempo o benfica
aceitou mostrar de fantástico mas não
sei se foi por obra e graça de junho foi
por obra e graça de jesus projeto
montagem da mãe em 2007 se vocês forem o
youtube puserem jogador do mundo messi
ronaldo messi e eu repórter fez uma
reportagem sobre mim
o director disse moretto é fã do
mourinho eu tenho um irmão de lu dois
chapéis o aumento dias eu e minha irmã
eu escrevi uma irmã respondeu em três
gestões
só com esta frase claro que sim eu pago
pela ucrânia eu fui
quando eu encontrei um pouco dura
complementá-lo tava assim eu não estava
com frio
ele estava nervoso e nossa primeira
conversa foi esta frente a frente um com
o outro fala nunca da equipe powell sabe
mexer sim senti calor suficiente já que
os 27 pretendem avaliar
estamos a trocar idéias e trocar isaías
só para vocês perceberem que o edifício
não signifiquem possível e que o pior
inimigo nós próprios somos nós
ele sabe tirar a carta mas não consigo
é impossível para mim e eu tentava
imprimir um vírus no eládio paramés aqui
de braga que embora eles também têm
possivelmente com a treta que andava
andava está a andar aqui o episódio como
hilário segunda falha a memória foi uma
sexta vítima estava acusada mostrar de
topo são aceitos terá de continuar seu
carro à porta e assim foi
vem tirar a carta um pedido de ajuda de
um sinal de fraqueza e não de caráter
não podemos ter vergonha de pedir ajuda
é sinal do caráter o que ajuda
diretamente na verdade é que eu consegui
tirar a carta e no mês de maio tirei a
carta e arrancar entre madrid e quando
estacionei o carro à porta do centro de
estágios de madrid
eu te amo do carro e olhou e leasings a
única frase que eu estava fazendo lá sem
desta nestes pequenos 18 minutos que eu
vou fazer os 20km próprio resto é resto
estão nestas duas barreiras duplas e
taxas que é impossível em duas sentenças
a batalha das nossas vidas não é contra
os outros e contra nós
quantas vezes nós acordamos de manhã nos
olhamos as paredes já não consigo eu não
faço eu não vou te derrubar essas
barreiras e ganhava a batalha contra si
próprio
temos que acreditar em ti filho do valor
e quando você sai de madrid era uma
notícia que eu ia ser pai é fã da coréia
e eu era naquele dia do nascimento
gustavo que estava ter a máquina já era
tarde no tempo era se estiver em pé como
filho 41 10 um empurrão eu caí e que
medo de deixar aqui o meu filho e mesmo
não ser o pai
as expectativas que eu tinha no dia do
nascimento gustavo que tem o nome do
médico que acreditam em mim vocês a
mensagem resistiram à parte muitas vezes
vamos lá após levar um carrinho lá pra
trás pra frente
levo estava a passar lá para limpar e
enfermeira como suíço que tinha que
superar os meus medos um pouco estava
disse tom é seu
acredita tudo podia evitar maior
empurrão das suas vidas e nunca deixava
cair naquele dia e foi a única vez que
senti o meu coração totalmente
preenchida e sabe o que é preciso fazer
vocês lembram do filme o rei leão que
punam filha do rochedo abrir a janela da
maternidade independentemente está no
quinto andar pegar no meu filho e gritar
bem alto com aquelas pessoas que enviam
todo na praia
agora sim não levou pena
é por isto falta apenas a apresentação
de problema disse
não existe isso foi a chave para vencer
lembrando que o excel
essa dor pior inimigo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o dia
[Música]
obrigado
[Aplausos]